so my understanding is that in the 1960s  and 70s continuing into the 80s there  was a growing movement within the  academy coming out of post-modernism so  post-modernism is sort of this idea that  material reality doesn't exist and so  coming out of post-modernism came queer  theory which was the idea that the  material reality of biological sex  doesn't exist however if a bunch of  academics had tried to persuade ordinary  average everyday americans across the  political spectrum that the material  reality of biological sex doesn't exist  they wouldn't have been able to do it my  argument is that they invented the term  transgender to make it sound as though  there is a coherent category of people  who are being deprived of civil rights  but that's just not true